Hello, nice to meet you.
For the past two years, Wageningen University has been working very closely with Google....
...to use cutting-edge technology to look deeper into communication with plants.
Hello.
We collected an incredible amount of information.
Using automated machine learning, we turned this information into new rudimentary language,...
...which is becoming more and more sophisticated over time.
The more we listen to nature, the more we discover the amazing things it has to say.
What do you want?
Water, please.
We've applied all this research into our latest product, Google Tulip.
We're rolling out the tulip language in the beginning of April,...
...but we're already well underway with several updates.
Hello.
No.
Cactus.
Leave me alone.
Tulip is a breakthrough in human-plant communication,...
...letting users around the world communicate with any tulip.
Okay, Google.
Play my favorite music.